今日はこのアリスカの例の説明のところなんです
あの ある この前から読んでみるとわかりますけど
このクマーラカッサパというお坊様がこの森の中に生活していた時は
このある人からこのアリスカのなぞなぞですか
質問を出されたんですね
アリスカがありますけど
そのアリスカは夜 うーん
煙を出していて 昼燃えちゃうと
で 夜煙を出して昼燃えるこのアリスカについて
この それでまあ ブラームのウェワーハン
まあブラフマンが来て
こういう風に言うんだと
サッタンアーダーヤ アビッカナ
このアリスカを何か道具を持ってきて掘ってみなさいと
それでこのアリスカを掘ってみる
掘ってみると 最初に あの
ランギ 最初に見えるのはこのかんぬきですね
で 剣を持って掘っていると
まず あの かんぬきが見えると
そこでこのブラフマン人が
賢者が この かんぬきを取り除きなさいと言うんですね
で かんぬきを取り除く
で さらに掘りなさいと
さらに掘ると この次に出てくるのはカエル
アリスカを掘るとカエルが出てくるんですね
それでカエルですよと言ったら
じゃあカエルも取り除きなさいと
さらに掘りなさい さらに掘ると
岐路  あ 岐路が見つかる
分かれた道ですね  で 分かれた道が見つかるんですね
それで分かれて それからそれも取り除きなさいと
さらに掘ってみなさいと
で さらに掘っていくと
何か器 容器が見つかるんですね
容器も取り除きなさいと言うんですね
で 次に  カメ  カメが見つかるのでさらに掘ると
それでカメも取り除くんですね
取り除きなさいと さらに掘ってみなさいと
で さらに掘ってみると
この  土佐津状が見えます
土佐津状見つかるんですね
それも取り除いてさらに掘りなさいと言われて
それさらに掘ってみると
また肉の塊が 肉片見つかるんですね
それで肉片も取り除きなさいと言われて
さらに掘りなさいと で
さらに掘ると この龍というか蛇見つかるんですね
で 蛇が見つかりましたと
龍見つかりましたと そうすると
龍だったらそのまま置いておきなさいと
いじってはいけないんだと
龍を打ってはいけませんと
龍に対して礼をしなさいと
で それで掘ることをやめるんですね
龍に出会ったら もうそれ以上掘れなくなっちゃうんですね
で この  なぞなぞですね
それの意味は このクマラーカッサパ尊者はもう知るわけじゃないし
クマラーカッサパ尊者にこれはお釈迦様かお釈迦様の弟子以外は誰にもこの意味はわからないんだと
ですから そういう誰かに聞いてみなさいということになるんです
それでクマラーカッサパ尊者がこの
お釈迦様に会って お釈迦様にこの例えを言って説明を聞くんですね
それで今日はお釈迦様の説明
ワン
ミコーティコービクーイマスサエタンチャトゥマハーブーティカッサカーヤッサアビワチャナンマーターペッティカサンバヴァッサオーダナクンマースーパチャヤッサア
ニッチュッダハナパリマッドナヴェーダナヴィッドハンサナダンマッサ
それでアリスカと言ったのは体ですよ
人の体ですよ 体については仏教の定義がありまして
一般的な考え方とは違うかもしれませんですけど
仏教で体っていうのは四大要素から身体なる身体
で アリスカにしたっても
ただ土でできているもので
体というものも四大元素からできているものですよと
四大元素っていうのは自然のものだと思ったら
それぐらいのことで 別に厳密な説明は要らないと思いますけど
一応経典を理解する人にとってはそんなに厳密な定義は要りませんし
地水火風と四大元素がありますね
地といえば土でよろしいし
水は水でよろしいし 火は火でよろしいし
風は空気でよろしいんです
体の中で土と水と熱と空気があって
それで体ができているんだと
だから水分単純に考えているんですね
体っていうのは単なる普通の物体
物質と全く同じものだと
それよりあまり評価はしてないんです
それでマータペッティカサンバヴァッサ
体っていうのはこのただまあ父母から最初は始まるものですね
サンバラっていうのは生まれですね
現れですね それは父と母から最初に現れる体です
それからオーデナ プンマス
ウパチャヤス 父と母から小さな体が作れますけど
それはいろいろご飯やらいろんなお菓子やら
そういうものを入れて入れて入れて大きくするんですね
それからこの体っていうのは
父と母から最初の小さい体が出てきて
それからそれにいっぱいいろんなご飯を入れて入れて入れて大きくすると
それだけではなくて 体がアニッチャ
ずっとそういうことから見ても
体がずっと変わっていくものなんですね
ご飯とか何か入れないとそれで壊れていっちゃうし
ですから体っていうのはいつでもいろいろご飯入れてご飯入れてご飯入れて支えておかないとすぐ壊れてしまうということで
アニッチャっていうのはすぐ壊れてしまう
ウッチャーダナっていうのは
隠しておかなくちゃいけないというかね
チャーダナっていうのは隠すということで
ウッチャーダナっていうのはこの体の上でいろんなもので隠す
注釈書の説明だったら
体っていうのはものすごい臭い
体持っている本人にしても
随分我慢できないほど臭いんです
ですからそれは隠さないと
そういうことで いろんな方法で体の悪臭を隠すんだと
で パリマッダナ パリマッダナっていうのはいろんなものを塗っておくということで
いわゆるその場合は服を着せたりとかっていうこともあります
次のことはパリマッダナ
パリマッダナっていうのはだいたいマッサージに使う言葉なんですけど
で まあマッサージもする必要は体にあるんですけど
いつでもみんなマッサージするわけじゃないんですけども
とにかく体を動かしているんですね
いろいろ運動したり動かしたりしているんですね
体を全く動かさないで置いておいちゃうと
それでもう生きていられなくなっちゃうんです
で 大変なことになるんです
すぐ腐ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから もうずっと体を動かして動かして動かして置いておかなくちゃいけないんですね
だからもうものすごい
はっきり言えばすごいこの手入れしにくいものなんですね
何か何か置物のようにちょっと拭いて
綺麗にどこかに置いておいて
忘れてやってもいいということではないんです
ずっと 24時間これを動かしておかないと
で 壊れていく 腐ってしまっちゃうんですね
だから病気になってベッドに寝たっても
やっぱりずっと動いているんですね
まあそれそれで一応健康な人っていうのは
もうかなり体を動かしておかなくちゃいけないんですね
それはもうパリマッダナっていうことなんですね
次の言葉はベーダナ・ヴィッダンサナ・ダンマス
ベーダナっていうのは
そうやってずっと毎日ご飯を入れて
また悪臭を隠しておいて
ずっと運動させてあげて
面倒を見てあげたってもベーダナ
壊れていく どう頑張っても壊れることは避けられないんですね
ヴィッダンサナっていうのは
あの まあ最後の言葉はこの
ヴィッダンサナ ヴィッダンサナっていうのは壊れていく
ベーダナっていうのはまあしょっちゅう壊れること
ヴィッダンサナっていうのはもう全部壊れてもう終わってしまうことなんですね
もう修理できない状態にも壊れてしまうんですね
それが体ですよと あまりこの人気に出てくる言葉ではないんですけどね
まあまあ かなり反対されますけどね
この間も質問がありまして
この私はこのまあ体単なる物体ではないかとね
まあ机とかね 建物とか
そういうものと全く同じものではないかということに怒られちゃって
怒られたっても まあ何の返事もできないんですね
私にとっては ブッダ教えてないことは言うわけにもいきませんし
で それでも私は間違っているんだと
私と机が語れないんだからといって
机に知識がないと言ってはいけませんと
ということで うーん どうすればいいんでしょうかと
私もわかりません ただ
そこはものすごい頭のいい人でしょうね
椅子には本当は認識があると
でも私たちとはまあ語らないだけで
そんなことは言えないということしかないんですね
だからこのまあ 我々は単純で
仏教は単純で考えるんですよ
皆さんの日本の世界で考えているような
すごい高度な思考はないんです
で だから私の論理っていうのは
まあ誰とも絶対コミュニケーションが取らないゆえに心コミュニケーション機能があるという理屈は私にはわからないんですね
全くコミュニケーションが取れないがゆえにコミュニケーション機能があるという理屈ですが
それは私にはちょっと私の頭では理解できない
私の理屈では絶対コミュニケーションしてくれない
ですから コミュニケーション機能がないという方があのいくらか理解できます
だからもうやっぱり仏教は合ってないなと思いますね
あまり単純すぎて まあ他の仏教の方がね
もっと高度な仏教の方がいいかもしれませんですけど
まあそれで私はああいったのは
私にとっては一杯証拠があるんだと
100%とは言えません
机に心がない 絶対ですとは言えませんだけど
わかりませんだからね
コミュニケーション取ってないんだけど
でも机はコミュニケーション取ってくれないっていうことにはいっぱい証拠があるんだと
でもその人にとっては 1つも証拠がないんだと
だから 0対 1 でも 1 の方が勝ちですよ
だから机にコミュニケーション機能があるんだということには証拠 0
私には 1 じゃなくていくらでもありますね
机は私と語ってないんだと
コミュニケーション取ってないんだということには
ですから たくさんあるにも関わらず
私はただたくさんなくても一つだけでもあるんだと
だから 0 対 1 だけでも
私は私の方が正しいと思いますけどと
でも認めてくれなかったんですね
やっぱりそれでも間違いと
で やっぱりそれに出された反論というのは
この  日本ではそういうふうに思ってないんだと
すべてのものには心 魂というものがあるんだと
[背景音楽]だからそれも私にわからない理屈なんですね
日本人が何か考えてるんだからこそ
それは絶対的な宇宙の法則ですね
だから宇宙の構造のすべての真理っていうのは
日本人がどう思っているかっていうことなんです
だから日本人が宇宙や生命すべて創造した神であるならば
まあその理屈私にはわかりますけどね
やっぱりどうもこの国では仏教は語る場所じゃないんだと
ものすごい理屈が もう単純理屈は貶されるんだなとね
まあそれで随分痛感しましたけどね
でも公の場だからね 私にもなかなか遠慮してしゃべらなくちゃいけないしね
まあ堂々と自分たちが神やということでしょうにね
日本人が神様であって
すべてのものを創造した存在ならば
なんでと逆に行きたくなるんですね
もう石ころやら何でも信仰して
もう体中お守りだらけで
いろんなものに頼っているんですかと聞きたくもなるんですね
だから言いたいのは そういう喧嘩ではなくて
この仏教っていうのはすごい単純な論理なんです
嫌だったらやめてもいいんです
すごい我々にとってはものすごいもうもう難しい論理でなきゃ理解しませんというならば
それはそれで結構ですけどね
でも私から見れば 日本人が何か考えてるんだからこそ
それが絶対的真理だっていうのはちょっと傲慢ではないかなと
で それにまた次に出したポイントは
この植物と石とかね もう話してる人々がいるんだと
だから誰かが石と喋ってるんだからと言って
石には喋る機能があるんだと私は信じる必要ありますかね
石と喋る機能 石とコンタクトコミュニケーション取れるならば
人間にはどんな人間にも取れる必要あるでしょうに
人間の中でも それまた日本の中でも
人間の中でいったって日本だけで
日本の中でもすべての日本人ではなくて
誰か一人二人ぐらい石とよく喋っている
だからその人が喋ってるんだから
石に心がある 木に心があると私が決めなくちゃいけないんですね
それが絶対的真理だと
それはどんな理屈でしょうか
またわからなくなっちゃうんですね
っていうことは 日本人の中でも
どこかに行って この木と電信柱と元気
おはよう こんにちはと言っている人は
もうものすごい知識人で
日本人みんな神様なんですけど
神様の中でももっと優れている
もう絶対的な神様なんですね
それは信じなさいと言って
私の理屈は潰したんだと
本当に潰されたんですね
だから私の反論というのは
その人は病気じゃないかと
みんなに青く見えるものが一人に白く見えるんだったら
誰の視力をチェックするべきですかね
人 人  1万人に何か絵を見える見せる
見せてみんなこれは青いですよと一人で
いえ 違います それはもう白いですと言ったら
この 1万人の人ははいわかりました
これは白ですと 我々は間違ったんだと
と言うべきですかね 誰の視力をテストするべきかと
まあとにかくそこら辺で
私の話と一般の世界の理屈っていうのは
ちょっと合わない 噛み合わないところだけは確かにあります
それは私にとってはどうにもならないことなんですけど
私はですからこの だからでしょうね
何年  10年も経って喋っていても
まだまだ全然ね 理解していないと
だから理解できます 別に自分の思考が正しいと思っても
我々正しいんだけど この人はこんなこと言ってるんだよとぐらい理解できると思いますけどね
とにかくこの体に対しては
仏教はただの物体で見ているんです
この尊いものとかね 神の作り
神が作った大事なものとかね
そういうふうには思ってないんです
ただ地水火風でできている体で
例えばもう父母から出てきたところで
一生懸命毎日毎日毎日物質を入れて入れて入れて大きくしなくちゃいけないし
いくら大きなってもずっと壊れっぱなしで
それからものすごい悪臭でしょうし
だからそれは悪臭をずっと毎日消さなくちゃいけないし
体は悪臭といったところで怒られたこともありますからね
何言うんですか？おかしいと私が
みんなに病人が精神病気にいこうかなと思いますけどね
でも仏教ではそう思ってるんです
だから体はすっごいこのもう香水作る工場のようにすごい美しく変わりがあると思ったら
それはそれで自由でよろしいし
で  1週間ぐらいはお風呂に入らないでいてみればね
どういうことかと わかりますけどね
でもまあ感情で認めたくないっていうことはね
まあそれはもう真理は分からなくなるということなんですけどね
まあだから悪臭が出てくるからで
いつでもそれをもうなんとか隠さなくちゃいけない
それはウッチャーダナっていうことで
それでそこまでやったっても
常に体を動かしておかないとまた壊れる
だからずっと動かして動かしておいておくと
それやったってもそっちゅう壊れる
そっちゅう故障する それなんとか何とか修理して置いておいたっても
最終的にまた壊れてしまうという物体であると
だから椅子やら机と比べたってもより弱いんですね
椅子だったらこの椅子はまあ平気でもうこれぐらい年
年  40年はまあ大丈夫やとということを言えますけど
体については明日まで大丈夫やっていうことでも言えないんですね
いつ壊れてしまうかっていうことはわからないんです
まあそれはまあ体に対する仏教の見方
だからこのアリ塚に例えているんですね
まあアリ塚っていうことも感覚的に言ってることで
あのインド文化については
もうよくアリ塚っていうのはまあそっちゅうあることで
日本ではないんですけど
かなり大きいもので 大体この 1メートルとか 1メートル半ぐらいはアリ塚っていうのは土の上から出てくるもので
まあアリ塚といったっても
これはあのまあシロアリだと思いますけどね
塚作るのはシロアリなんですね
で それはまあちょうど体って例えたっても構いませんし
アリ塚にはいっぱい穴が出てきますね
だからシロアリがこの空気を通るために大きなもう手でも何でも中に出しても
大きなダクト これぐらい大きいダクトいっぱいあっちこっちで作ってあるんです
それでも風が吹いちゃうと
ざーっと中にすごい勢いで風が入るんですね
風通しはすごくいいんです
アリ塚の中に で あの それからアリ塚がどのように作られますかと
小さな砂 1粒 砂ではないんですけど
土をね  1粒1粒持ってきて
立てて立てて立てて作るものなんですね
シロアリ 1匹1匹 自分の口でこんなちっちゃな見えないぐらい小さな土
ちょっと持ってきて この自分の唾液でそれを混ぜてポツンと置いておく
それでまた次のアリが来て
またもう一つ もう見てもこんな小さい 1粒のこの小さな
この大体砂 1個ぐらいの
それも小さな住まいとぐらいの大きさなんです
そんな大きなものは使えませんだから
その割に そんなことで
このもう 1ヘクタある 2ヘクタぐらいの中
土の中で大きなものを作りますけどね
上に出てくるのはほんのちょっとですけどね
そんなものを作られますかと
やっぱりすごい早く作るんです
体の場合も同じく細胞 1個 1個もう分裂して成り立てるものなんですね
最初は 1個の細胞が それがもう大きくなって大きくなって
どんどんどんどんものすごいもうたくさん細胞が体がもうできているんですね
それからいっぱい体の中にも穴があるんですね
ありすかと同じく まあそういうことでも例えているんだと
で このそれからありすかといえばすごい危険なものでと
これは普通の感情なんですね
不幸なものだと思っているんです
決してこのインド人のいろいろインドの迷信というのはいっぱいありますから
方位学とかね もありますし
それから建物を作る場合は
その土地の状況とかね
いろんな星の占いいろんな学問で学問とは言わないんですけど
仏教ではそういうものにはいろんなそうやってこの
学問 知識で占って計算してみるんですね
その場合は 人が買った土地であろうとも
そちらにどこかでもありすかがあったならば
そこら辺は絶対建物を作らないんですね
建物を作ったら その家に住む人々はみんなものすごい不幸になるんだと
だからありすかの上では決して建物を作らないという迷信があるんです
あれは中国風に何か丸い円盤を持ってきて測る
あれは方位学ですか？風水
風水と似ているものなんですけどね
だからそれはテキストいろいろありまして
まあまあ インド人はあまり武器は作り
武器じゃない道具は作りません
使いませんだけど 全部暗記して覚えておくんですね
だからそのいろいろ特色を見て暗記していますから
もう何 100芸ぐらいもそのその風水学で
それでもうこれだったら北の方にこういうものがあったらこういう結果ですよと
西の方にこういうものがあったらこういう結果ですよとか
まあまあ風水で言って
家建てるならばここら辺だよと
で 例えばこの人が歩くところ
道路 道路の側に建物を造ってはいけないと
そうすると貧乏になるんだと
で 土地のど真ん中にも作ってはいけないんですね
罰が当たると で それいろいろ決まってるんです
だから自分の土地の中で人間の領域という場所があるんです
そこは計算して ここら辺は人間の領域ですと
そちらに作ると だからメインの柱はそちらにつけて建物を造ると
他の領域に連絡してもいいんです
作ってる途中で連絡してもいいんだけど
まだ一番先につける 柱はそちら人間の領域につけなくちゃいけない
それで神社寺とかを作る場合は
そこを作ってはいけないんですね
その場合はこの 土地の真ん中に作らなくちゃいけない
それはまあ 神の領域がありまして
梵天の領域があります
人間の神の梵天だから
梵天の領域ってことで作らなくちゃいけないんですね
で 神の領域というところに柱つけていいというのは
このやっぱり宮殿とかね
そういう大臣たちとかね
もう将軍とか そういう人々が自分のお城を作る場合は
そちらにそちらから始まるんです
でも決して真ん中に行ってはいけないんです
そうやって風水っていうのはインドにもあります
で 仏教は信じないんだけど
そういうものを信じているでしょうね
まあそれはどうかっていうとどうでもいいんですけど
で だからこのありすかがあったら
それはもう避けるということは
この不幸のためなんですね
だからその背景を理解するともっとわかると思いますね
ありすかというのは体のことやというと
仏教はいかに体は評価してない
褒め称えてないということと
世界では全く逆で 体のことはもうできるだけ褒め称えて
もう人格化するんですね
死んじゃったら その人の骨とかはもうすごい大変大事なんです
そうやっても家にまで持ってきて
それを拝んだりするっていうのは
それはまあ仏教のやり方ではないんですね
他の国々で見たことのあるこの中国の人々とかね
やっぱり人が死んじゃったらおひやいとかね
家で集団でやってますけど
テーラワーダ仏教になっちゃうと全部捨てるんです
全部捨てれば家を綺麗にしちゃうんです
それを捨てたことは戦争を大事にしないという意味じゃないんです
戦争をすごく大事にする
それでちゃんと戦争に供養したり
そういうことはするんだけど
ああいう迷信的なことはやめたりもします
ですから それは一般の俗世間の思考で体がすごい神様ですよと思っていたりして
生きているよりも死んだ時はもっと価値がありますね
だから私が言ったら なんでこれそのまま遺体そのまま
なんで家に置いておかないんですかと
なんでそれ燃やして灰だけね
骨だけ持ってくるんだ
遺体そのまま持って置いた方がね
完璧でもっと立派でしょうしね
干してでもね  ただの物体としては見ているのです
とにかく で そういうことで
ちゃんとこのアリ塚に例えるのはそういうわけなんですね
ありがたいものじゃない
できればもう逃げろと
アリ塚の中にいっぱい動物
穴があるんだから いっぱいこの怖い動物たち隠れてるの
いくら大体このコブラとかね
毒蛇なんかはもうそのところアリ塚なんです
あるいは自分のためにそれ作るんだけど
この空気のエアダクトいっぱいできてるでしょうに
そちらには白アリはいないんです
丁寧にすごいすごいソフトに作るんです
壁は この空気が通る壁は
だからもういろんなトカゲ種類やらね
それからヘビやらね 中にそっと入って生活できる
ウサギにでも何のことなく中に入って生活できる
ウサギはそうすると身の安全考えて自分で穴を掘ってますけど
あれの中に入れたら ヘビがいたらまあそれでもう食べられちゃいますからね
だからこの体っていうのはそういうものであると
危険なものであると どう見たってもみんなアリ塚でアリ塚ばっかしであちこち歩いたりして何するかというと口が穴でしょ
一つのダクトなんですね
口で何やってるんですかね
もう悪口ばっかり人をけなすことばっかり喋って
もうみんな喧嘩やらね
ほとんどもう人類の平和まで壊してしまっちゃうでしょうに
もうありったけのこの危険
もう爆弾 もうもう一つのミサイル発射台みたいなものなんですね
で 口から目からものを見て何するんでしょうかというと
危険なことばっかりで
見ただけで何か見たら腹が立ってそれを壊すとかいくらでもあるでしょうし
だから耳からでも同じことでしょうに
まあそうやって 結局体の体からも危険ばっかりのことをやってるんだから
ちょうどいい例えになっちゃうんですね
で 夜煙を出して煙を出して
昼はもう燃えるんだと
それはそれは簡単ですね
ヤンコウビッケウェーディワーカンマンテーヤーラッバラッティンアヌミタッケティアヌヴィチェラティアヤンラッティンドゥーマーヤナ
人々は昼何をするかと
昼の仕事についてやるべきことについて夜はずっと考えてるんですね
明日すること あれしなくちゃいけない
これしなくちゃいけない
あの人にこう言わなくちゃいけないと
そうやって夜はずっと考えてるだけ
考えて考えて昼になったらその行動する
ですから 夜ずっと考えていることは煙を出していることで
煙出てからもう炎が出ますからね
それで朝になってくると炎が出てくるから
考えたものは行動に移すと
カワエナワーチャンマナサ
それで体のこと 体のたとえ
たとえの説明 次にこのブラームのエーヴァーマーハ
それでブラモンが来てこのように言いますと
たとえストーリーの次のポイント
ブラームノウティコビッキュウタターガタッサーエタンアディバチャナンアラハトーサンマサンブッダッサ
ブラームナ ブラモンというのはタターガタッサ
如来に使う同義語ですよと
この場合は タターガタ
お釈迦様ですね ブッダですね
アラハトーサンマサンブッダッサ
正覚者に悟ったお釈迦様にブッダに使う言葉
ですからブラームのエーヴァーマーハっていうのはそれでブッダが出てきて
こういう風に言うんですね
このアビスカを掘りなさいと
大事にしなさいではなくて
なんか怪しい煙が出る
炎が出ると だったら掘ってみなさいと
推測は認めないんです
掘ってみろ 誰に言うんです
スメド スメダという人に言うんですね
スメダっていうのは これは人の名前に使う言葉なんですけど
大勢の男たちに呼ぶスメダという名前を付けます
だいたい男性に使う名前ですけどね
女性に使う場合はスメダーという風に使えます
スメダー スメダ スメダーヴィーはあまり使えないんですね
ちょっと語呂が良くないね
その場合はスを取ってメダーヴィーだけにするんです
で スメダといえば だいたい男性に使う名前で
一般的な名前です 意味はすごい頭の賢いっていう
頭がいいという まあそういう風な意味のね
漢字ででも人に名前を付けるでしょ
で 悟るとかね それも言えばね
まあ頭がいいということでしょうにね
そこでこのメダー メダーじゃない
スメドというのはセーカッサエタンビックノアディワチャナン
セーカッサアディワタナン
セーカっていうのは学生という意味なんですね
普通文字の意味はね だから仏教の場合は仏教徒になって
仏教の信者さんになって修行することが
なんか宗教に入って修行信者になって修行するふうな意味で取ってないんです
ある研究所に研究員として入ったっていう意味なんですね
だから研究員なんですね
その研究所に入ったらしっかりと科学的に研究しなさいと
ある学校に入って入学したならば
もう学生なんですね だったらしっかりと勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから このセーカというのは信者さんという意味なんですけど
信者という意味ではないんです
何かを恐れて信仰して
助けたまえとか なんとかね
守り給えとかね 清め給えとか
そうやってまあふうなことをする意味ではないんですね
ある研究所 それに入ってちゃんと研究する
それで研究するといっても
この世の中であるこの腐っている思考と混ぜて研究するのは全く非科学的だから
それは認めません それが間違っているんだから
仏教研究所に来るんです
だから体が尊いものやと
まあ宇宙のエネルギーでできているんだから
まあ宇宙と一緒で永遠不滅ですよとかね
で 中国で考えたような気で自分の体を新しく作っちゃえば
永遠に仙人になって死にませんよとかね
そういうふうな考え方はないんですね
ただの土でできているものとかね
それで仏教研究所に入ってきて
じゃあ仏教の修行で合わせて気を開発する方法とかね
中国の昔の仙人たちがこの気をどんどんどんどん増えて増やして増やして増やして
気だけで物体の体が作るんだ
そうすると元の体が壊れるんだけど
作った体が気でできた体が永遠に残るんだと
それで不老長寿になるんだとかね
それで早くも気を育てるために仏教の瞑想法で何かないかとか調べるって
それはもう邪教的なことで
だから瞑想研究所といっても
そんなもういい加減なやり方は認めるわけにはいきませんね
だからあれと混ぜて これと混ぜて
あの師匠と混ぜるといったら
それはその師匠自体が正しければいいんです
それはもう根本的に間違っているんだから
汚いもので混ぜたら 混ぜられたものは汚いっていうのは我々の立場
仏教は単純だからね だからあなたの教えも素晴らしいんだから
じゃあ私は今までこういう教え信仰していたんだから
それに混ぜて使いませてっちゃっても
こちらは認めません でも向こうは自由だからやってもいいんですけど
それでちょっと批判すると
あんたは何でも批判して
もうなんでそんなに人のことを馬鹿にするんですかと
頭が悪いんじゃないかと言われたっても悪いんです
そうしょうがないんです
私たちにとっては いくら高価なごちそうであろうとも
それはクソと混ぜちゃうと
もう全体的に汚いと食べられない
大量のクソの中にちょっと食べられる食べ物をちょっと混ぜただけで全部食べられるんだよという理屈はちょっとわからないんですね
ですから 頭は悪いまんまでいいんです
私の場合も だから仏教はお釈迦様がそういう立場で
そんないろいろ混ぜることは認めません
厳密に科学的に論理的に語っているんです
それで生かという言葉の定義で
ここまで余計なところまで言いましたけど
生かという言葉自体も大変かっこいい言葉なんです
学生という意味なんです STUDENT
ただのBELIEVERではないんです
何か信仰している すごい明るくて
もう何か研究所に入ってバリバリと研究し続けるという
だから仏教っていうのは自分というものを研究する研究所なんです
仏教っていうのはこの研究の仕方
方法論というのは研究はいい加減できないでしょうに
研究する場合はものすごい決まりっていうのはたくさんどうせついてきます
そこら辺に 例えばもう一生専業主婦で料理していたんだと
だから明日からロケット研究所に入ってロケットの研究すると言ったら
それは無理な話で ロケット開発研究所に入るんだったら
それはもうロケットやらね
航空やら いっぱい勉強しておかないと
私は十年も料理作ったんだから
かなり腕がいいんだよと言ったっても研究員にはなりませんしね
だから研究所と言えば
それなりのしきたり 決まりっていうのは当然成り立ちます
ですから 仏教という私の研究じゃなくて
私を研究する研究所なんです
だからどのように研究するべきかということは
まあはっきりと決まってます
そういうことで この聖歌っていうのは
まあ意味はスチューデントいう意味
あるいは研究員という意味なんですけど
そんな意味では日本訳できません
だから一応修行する人っていうことになるんですね
でも漢訳でも学学者と訳してるんです
有学無学という二言葉あるでしょ
漢訳でも有名な言葉で
それは成果成果というサンスクリット語でシャイクシャーサイキサーという言葉の漢訳なんですね
有学無学 そこで日本の方々の感じで言えば
有学は立派で無学はとんでもないということになるかもしれません
意味は違います 有学はっていうのは学問中
無学っていうのはもう学問卒業終了っていうこと
学ぶところなしということで無学なんです
学ぶところありということで有学と
だから有学無学で中国語でその用語を作ってるんです
だから中国語だったら誤解しません
日本で日本語で見ちゃうと
有学っていうのは学問あって立派な人で
無学っていうのは学問なくてバカやと思っちゃう可能性ある
それは日本語ではそういう風になっちゃいますけどね
でも中国語ではそうじゃないんです
有っていうのは動詞ですから
ですから有学ですよ 学も動詞なんですね
ですから学ぶところは今あります
現在進行形で あるいは学んでいる人
無の場合はこの学ぶものは終わります
だから非学と書いてないんですね
なぜ非使わないかというと
この無っていうのはすごいなんか神秘的な言葉なんですね
中国語では ないという意味なんですけど
なんかもう空っぽという意味ではなくて
すごい神秘的なんですね
争って書く場合は非という漢字使っちゃえばね
また漢字ミスぐらいありますけど
否定形のね その中でこの無使っちゃえば
ちょっと神秘的で宗教的で
ということですから 有学無学言葉ありまして
だから仏教の世界でも修行者っていうのは学者なんです
すごいかっこいい言葉を使ってます
言葉だけかっこいいわけじゃなくて
中身もかっこいい 中身がかっこいいんだからかっこいい言葉使ってるんです
きちんと学問的に研究するんだから
だからこのスメーデ これ掘りなさいよと言いましたね
それでスメーデって言ったのは
学者に使う言葉ですよ
どこでしたっけ スメードーティコービクセイカッセータンビクノアディバジャナン
あの学者の比丘に言うことですよと
ですから仏教は信じていますけど
修行しないと学者ではありません
出家はしているんだけど
ただ出家して儀式儀礼ばっかりやっているんだったら
ただの比丘であって学者という位はないんです
やっぱり道場に入って修行するか
経典にしつこく勉強して理解するか
そういうことをする時だけ聖歌と言うんですね
学者という言葉を使うんですね
それで次の言葉 サッタンティコービクアリアーエータンパンヤーヤアディバジャナン
サッタン 何かこの道具というか武器ですね
サッタンっていうのはこのウェポンという英訳すれば本当はウェポンなんですね
だから掘る道具ということなんですね
鍬でも何でもいいんです
とにかく道具ですね 道具は何なのかというと
アリアヤパンニャーヤアディワチャナ
アリアパンニャー パンニャーっていうのは知恵ですね
アリアっていうのは聖なる知恵
そこで知恵 はっきり区別しています
俗世間の人々にも知恵という言葉を使う権利があります
ウィスダムという言葉を使う権利があります
それはもう言葉だから
で 普通にね あの人には知恵がありますよとかね
学生も学生が 5人いるんだけど
一人はすごく知恵がありますよとかね
ということはまあまあ言えるし
でも俗世間でいう知恵ではありません
まあ俗世間の知恵はもう勝手でよろしいのです
机にも確実に知識があるんだぞと
まあ頑張って証拠を出せればいいんです
それは俗世間の知恵でよろしいのです
人類の一人だけ一つ言ったら
それが正しくて 人類言うことは間違っているというのは
まあ勝手にその理屈でよろしければ
それは同窓ということでね
それも知恵と思うならば
同窓知恵と思っても構いません
アリアという言葉は使わない
アリアっていうのは やっぱりお釈迦様は仏教の世界で特別に使っている言葉で
だから聖なる知恵 聖なる知恵っていうのは
この単純な論理で客観的に物事を見ることなんです
単純な論理でなければ
無常はわからないんです
妄想で固定概念で見ると
永久的に無常は発見できないんです
だからあっちこっちからゴミ拾いして
この知識というゴミいっぱい拾って
その中から一生懸命無常について考える
シンポジウムやる 国際会議もやるとかよくやります
また私に今国際会議に参加しなさいという招待状がありますけど
で まあ見ただけで腹が立ってしまったんですけど
まあかなりの学者が集まります
とにかく そうやってこのいろんな知恵をね
医学の有名な人が無常について語るとかね
心理学の有名な人が無常について語るとかね
で カント派の人が来て無常について語るとか
ユンゲの人が来て どうでもいいんですけど
勝手にそんなことはね
ゴミはゴミそのものだからね
だからそうやって誰かの尺度で無常を語っても
それが無常じゃないんです
もう汚れているんです
ずっと仏教を研究する学者の方々はそれをやってきたんですね
どんな汚染物質と汚しますかと
汚してくれないと理解してくれないんですね
なぜならば 自分の知識はもともと汚れているんだから
はめないんですね 汚れてない知識は異物で感じちゃうんですね
経典そのまま読んじゃうと
なんだかちょっとわからないなとかね
現代人にはこれだったら気に入らんと
だから現代人に気に入るために
じゃあまあ ユンゲの思想と混ぜてあげましょうと
現代人がユンゲのあの教えが正しいと思ってるんだから
ああそうですか 似てるところあるんですか
仏教って偉いね ありがたいね
それで全然仏教が分かったことにならないんです
ユンゲの思想に当てはまるところがあったんだから
そう思うんであって そこで
世界のどんな哲学者のどんな心理学者の思考にでも当てはまるところは必ずあるんです
仏教で だから言ってその人の思想ではないんです
合うところがあるんだって言って
だから アリアパンニャーっていうのは
聖なる智慧っていうのは
単純論理で いろんなものと混ぜることなく
事実を客観的に ありのままに客観的に見る
見ると無常を発見できる
体をありがたいと思っている間では
永久的に発見できません
体はただ腐っている物体だと見ない限りは
で 体にものを触れるたびに
心がすごく汚れて汚れて汚くなっているんだよという風な
無価値で見ない限りは
無常っていうのは発見できません
だから 見る態度っていうのは無価値論で見るんですよ
無価値論というのは強引に作った哲学ではないんです
どう見たってものには価値がないんです
一時的な 相対的に価値が成り立つだけであって
価値 独立した価値っていうのはないんです
金に価値があるかというと
言うとそれ価値がないんです
一時的で相対的にあるものなんですね
金そのものはもうただの金属一種で
金属というのも人間であって
人間でいなければ 金は金
金は金属やというラベリングで成り立たないんですね
そこで人間が金に価値つけてあって
だからって普遍的な価値があるかと言って
そうでもないんですね
例えば 子供に金の価値がありますか？全く価値がない
我々は山の中で遭難している
金の価値がありますか？何の価値もない
ヒマラヤででもどこでも
ものすごい雪嵐に遭遇して
雪崩に遭遇して 自分がどこかにもう洞穴に隠れてて
全部指ばっかで それでダイヤと宝石と金つけているんだと
何の価値もないでしょうに
そこら辺で動物でも雪の流れでぶつけて死んだ死体があったならば
動物 それには価値があるんです
その場合は ネズミでも死んで
もう見つかるんですね
自分が隠れてるから なんかネズミ死んでるんではないかと
その死んでるネズミの死体には価値があるんですよ
首にかけてる金のネックレスよりは
だから価値っていうのはそんなもので
相対的なものでも その瞬間にのみ機能するもの
だからその無価値論で物事を見なくちゃ
無常っていうのは発見できません
そこで人間にそれはものすごい難しいことなんです
だからお釈迦様 これは超越した智慧だと
出世間的な智慧だと 世俗的な智慧じゃないんだと
なぜお釈迦様は出世間的
超越と言ったんでしょうかというと
それはまた誤解しちゃうんですね
出世間的 超越と言ったら
これは超能力的で なんかものすごいものだと
だから全知全能のようなものやと
そういうふうな感じで受け取って
それであまり誰も悟ろうとしない
やっぱり自分には無理やと
そんなもう超越した智慧
これはちょっと無理やと
来世にしますと ということになっちゃうんです
これをテーラワーダの世界でもそう思っているんです
問題は人間によくあることで
スリランカでも一般人がもう悟ったと言えば
もう突然消えた その人物そのものが
だってもう普通じゃないんだと
悟ったならば 突然現れて突然消えたりしなきゃダメなんです
もう托鉢に来るのはいいんだけど
突然現れて食事をいただいて
すぐその場でもう消えるということでなきゃ認めません
ですから スリランカで悟った人はいないんです
誰も認めてくれませんよ
で 一般人の思考っていうのはそんなもんなんです
だからどういうことかというと
この俗世間の知識っていうのはすべて価値という土台に成り立っています
これがありがたい これがありがたいと
新しいものを発見したら
どんな角度で見るかというと
どのように見ればこれが価値があるかとわかりますかと
だから学問研究というのは価値を探すことなんです
科学研究っていうのは価値を探すことなんです
例えばこの細胞の中に入っている遺伝なんかはね
どうでもいいことだから
その焼いて食べればいいんですけど
別にもう DNA だからね
それ苦労して苦労して塩基配列はこういうことやと
そんなこと知らなくたっても
人間は生きて大きくなって死にますしね
昔の人と今は大した変わりがないし
なんでそこまで苦労するんですかと
言うと くだらんではないか
それから一生懸命価値を探すんです
じゃあこれからこの遺伝子情報の中でがんを作る原因見つかりましょう
人太らせる原因見つかりましょう
高血圧にする遺伝を見つかりましょう
それからその遺伝改良する方法を見つけ
そういう価値が出てくるでしょうに
あれほど膨大な研究をしたところで
価値があの がんを未然に防ぐことができたとかね
で 高血圧に治療が見つかりましたとかね
というぐらいで終わっちゃうんですね
それでもすごい価値やと
虫に食えない麦を開発しましたと
虫が食わない麦とかね
小麦とかね まあそれぐらいのことで終わっちゃうんです
虫が食ったっても別に
毒だから虫が食わない麦ですよとか言っても
だから何が偉いんだ ありがたいんですかね
それで人類は食料不足になるんだよと
それも自分たちのやり方が悪いんだからでしょうに
例えば 100グラムの牛肉食べる場合は 100
人の人間の食べ物ですよ
あれは 一人が 1食に 100人の食べ物を食べてるんだから
99人には食べ物ないってのは当たり前でしょうに
だから人間の 1食分作る場合はどれぐらい無駄するかというと
特に先進国々では一人一食食べたということは
大体 100人 200人の食べ物を食べているんです
それで更に向こうは開発するでしょうに
どうすれば 1食は 1000人分の菜料を食べられるかという研究になっちゃうでしょうに
そこですごい高価な牛肉 100グラム食べちゃうと
そちらの中に入っているのはコレステロールやいろんなものでしょうね
柔らかくなければいけませんとかね
体に毒なのに 日本だったら霜降りでなきゃ食べないでしょう
だから毒が入ってないと食べないんだ
それで毒薬食ったところでどうやってコレステロール減るかと
また自然の材料破壊するでしょ
またいろいろコレステロール減る
お茶やらね ヤブゾウやらね
いろんなものを飲まなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからどれほど一人の人間が一日千人二千人の分の地球の資源を壊してるんです
だから食料は不足なんです
それはアフリカのせいだと
南アジアのせいだと と言うんですね
だから人を殺して殺された人が犯罪だと
殺した自分が無罪で正しいという判決なんですね
人の家に泥棒に入って裁判にかけたところで
泥棒に入られた側が有罪で泥棒が無罪で弁償しなさいと
だから泥棒に入られた側が泥棒の交通費やら道具の値段やら全部払わなくちゃいけない
という理屈なんです だからそれは俗世間の理屈なんです
その理屈はもう先進国々が我々には怒りながら教えてくれるんです
ずっと馬鹿にされてるんです
でも結局はこの知識人はやっぱりまあ
やっぱり理屈はおかしいってこと知ってますけど
とにかく言いたかったのは
ＤＮＡの研究やらものすごいお金
まあ何兆単位で使って開発します
何ですかと 麦 小麦 それでその開発したお金まで払って
その種を買わなくちゃいけないということで
そんなことやったら それで地球の食料不足開発解決しますかね
だって種のかかる値段
まあそういうことで とにかく研究
科学研究っていうのは価値を見つかる
なんとか価値を見つかる
そこで地球の人類に一日二日食べるぐらい
あるいは第三国々だったら一年二年ぐらいでも
みんなに三食食べていられるぐらいのお金を作って
ロケット一つと宇宙船一つ
それを人類の役に立つんだと
その技術を使って何かこれできたんだと
例えばペンキとかね 燃えない材料今開発しましたと
軽くて硬いものができたと
それぐらいのことなの
それをまあ十年 二十年経ったところで言ってくれるんですね
そこでこの地球のどんなところでも狙って爆弾
原子爆弾をかけるために作った技術ね
あの GTS でしたっけ
GPS ですね  GLOBAL POSITION SYSTEM というね
それを開発してて それはもう二十年経ったところで
古い技術はもういらない
それで一般人に配っちゃったんですね
今カーナビとか使ってるのはその GPS なんですね
それにどれぐらいお金かかったかというと
それで今みんなお金払って使ってますね
もう結局価値がすごい大
ただ道案内して人に聞いても教えてくれますけどね
行く途中で車止まってどこ行けばいいんでしょうかとね
だから人に聞いても教えてくれることには
何兆円かかったと思いますかね
地球の財産 それでも価値があると我々は思ってますね
だから科学やら他の学問やら
我々の全ての思考っていうのは
どんな価値があるんでしょうかという思考
それが俗世間というのです
その土台を壊して何にも価値がないんだという事実
真理に来ることは出世間的なんです
それで突然消えるということはできないんです
それ知ったとしても だからなんで悟った人について
このテーラワーダ仏教の世界でも
空から来て突然現れてきて
超能力で神通力であれやってこれやってと
それも俗世間の考え方なんです
そうすると価値があるんですよ
価値で見てるんです 自分たちがアホでバカで何にもできない
でも悟った人にとってはすごいことできるんだぞと
価値があるんだよと 思っている
俗世間の考え方なんですね
だから悟るっていうことは来世にするぞっていうことになっているのも
それも俗世間の思考なんですね
価値が入れちゃって難しいんだから
じゃあ来世にしますと
だから出世間な知恵っていうのは
この無価値という台土台で見る
だから結局は土台を壊さなくちゃいけないんです
だから仏教の知恵が知ってる人の知識
パンニャー 智慧と俗世間の知恵っていうのはまるっきり正反対で違うもので
全く違う知恵なの だから出世間としか言葉ないんです
お釈迦様には お釈迦様の出世間という言葉自体もすごい合理的で論理的で的な言葉で
決して神秘的な言葉ではありません
さあ それで このスメーダっていうのは
道具の例えは何でしょうかというと
掘る道具はパンニャーですね
出世間のパンニャー アリアパンニャー
聖者の知恵 聖なる知恵
で このありすかを掘ってください
聖なる知恵で ありすかではなくて
体を観察しなさいということですね
アビッカナンティコービクヴィリアランバスエータンアディワチャナ
次に掘りなさいと言ったんですね
掘りなさい このありすかを掘るということはどういう意味かというと
この学者が知恵で 聖なる知恵で精進する
研究すること いわゆる修行することなんですね
ヴィリアランバス 頑張って修行してみる
精進努力して 努力して
研究してみることが掘ることなんですね
そこでもかんぬき見つかるんですね
体を研究すると 頑張って研究すると
まず見つかるのはかんぬきです
かんぬきっていうのはもう邪魔なんですね
ロックだから 鍵だから
もう掘れない 鍵かけてるんです
中何があるかはやっぱりわからない
もう全部閉鎖 我々の知恵に完璧に閉鎖されているんですね
だからずっと無知のままで人間が生きてるんですね
みんなにすごい鍵かけてるんです
いくら説法したっても
その鍵は開けられません
心の鍵は その鍵なんですね
かんぬき それは何なのかと
何でしたっけ？アヴィッジャヤエータンアジワチャナ
これはアヴィッジャ 無明ですよと
だからすべての生命が自分の心にすごいかんぬきをつけてるんです
もう絶対真理わからない
もう入らない 立ち入り禁止
そのかんぬきが無明というんですね
それは取り除きなさいと
ウッキパランギン かんぬきを取り除けというのはパジャハアビッジャン
無明を取り除けっていうことですよと
アビッカスメーデサッタンアーダーエ
さらに掘ってみなさい
さらに頑張ってみなさいと
だから修行が始まる時もある程度で無明はなくさないと
だから我々は一生懸命皆様の価値観を壊して
偉大なる日本の文化的な感情的なものを
私はもうざんざん悪口言って壊してますけど
それに腹が立たれたらしょうがないんです
しょうがないんですけど
結局それはしなきゃこの無明のかんぬきは壊れません
今まで価値があったとあったと思ったものは
もう宗教であろうが何であろうが
私はものすごい残酷にも否定していくでしょうに
そんなもの 私にとってはもう大きなお世話で
お節介しないで一人でいれば楽なんですけど
余計な人と喧嘩を売って
もう我慢できなくてみんなに喧嘩を売って回っているわけじゃないんで
私はハリネズミじゃないんです
でも針で刺してそれを破る
この膜をね 一つ一つね
破らなくちゃ いっぱい膜持ってる人がいっぱいいたいんです
こちらでも針を刺してその膜を破るんだから
だから私はいくらハリネズミだと思っても
何の膜も持ってない人にとっては何の痛みも快感もないんです
刺されるところがないんだから
だから私の話聞いてすごい気持ち悪かったとかね
なんかすごいなんかちょっともうカットしたくなったとかあったならば
それは自分が何か固定概念を持っていたということで
自分が何か無常無明というのを持っていたということで
だから説法をする場合は説法は二つあります
単なる単なる説法 それはすごい気持ちいいもんなんです
ありがたい話ですよと終わっちゃうんです
それも我々は一応訓練させてますけどね
みんなでみんなの感情
何と言いますか 小泉さんの言葉みたいに
もうみんなに賛成してもらう
そういうふうな説法の仕方もありますし
で 逆に人々をこの泥沼から追い出すという徹底した脅しの説法もあります
だから意味があるのは
この徹底した脅しの話なんです
お釈迦様が認めたのは
認めたのはそれなんです
説法してお釈迦様が言うのは
人をそうやってとことん責めて
責めて もうどうにもならないところまで責めてしまって
もう無明を破ってもらうと
だからそれは人気ある話ではないんです
とにかく だから説法 かなり正反対で
みんなに賛成してもらって
平和で無事終わる話 説法と
それでは決して無明は破れません
いい話でしたわということで終わっちゃうんです
で その場合はかなり御利益があります
そういう話をすると 仏教はかなり話は上手だから
そして言うことはちゃんと役に立つものを言うんだから
他の宗教の説法を聞いたよりはみんな感動するし
日常生活の役に立つし
ですから結構お布施なんかは入るんです
それでかなり豊かで贅沢している説法師たちがいますよ
豪華で ただちょっと一時間ぐらい喋るだけ
喋って終わったら まあありとあらゆるお布施なんかもらっちゃうと
でもそれはお釈迦様はこの御利益の道と解脱の道が全く正反対だよと
それはものすごく否定しているんです
で 解脱するために喋っちゃうと
まあお布施もらうどころではなくて
自分のものを持っていかれることもあります
あの人にご飯あげるなよと
とんでもないことを言うんだよと人にまで
だからこの間瞑想に来たある人がなんであんた日本にいるんですか？と
そればっかり聞くんですね
私はいくつかいくつかちょっと批判的なこと
なんであんたそれだったら日本にいるんですかと
だから言いたいことは口に出たんだけど
やっぱりよしましょうということで
まあちょっと話をちょっと脱線させちゃったんですけどね
自分が苦しんで もう何もできない愚か者で
なんとかもう助けてほしいということで来て
だから本人の欠点 ちょっとちょっとこういうことであなたはとかねと言ったところで
逆に何年か日本にいるんですかね
ちょっと論理的に言うと
私は日本にいたんだから
お前が来て話聞いてるななんかと聞きたいんですけどね
[笑い]やっぱりそういうの理屈っていうのはね
仏教の理屈とはね だから一番よく私に聞こう聞いた
みんなこのいつ国に帰るんですか？とにかくそれだけ早く帰ってちょうだいと
だからちょっと自分の問題はこんなちょっと何か解決してもらっちゃいますけど
だからあなたがいることは困りますよという理屈になるんですね
で いくらかバレちゃったんだからね
また日本にいると また日本のことバレちゃって困りますから
早く帰ってくださいと
だからやっぱりその無知のまんまでいたいという気持ちなんですね
こいつは日本人に恥かけるんだよと
だから恥かかせて恥かかせてるわけじゃないんだよ
問題があることは言ってるだけなんです
だから別にそれ日本人の問題というわけじゃない
いつでも言ってるでしょう
それは人類の生命の問題で
特別な日本人の問題じゃないんです
なんで私は特別日本人のことを批判しているんだと理解するんですかね
それ自体あまりにも高慢なんです
私たちは神様ですよと思ってることなんです
どんなにどんな人間でも
テーラワーダの人間でもみんな同じなんです
悟ってない限りはね もう同じことで恥かけるところっていうのはもうありすぎくらいあります
だからそこは 1つ1つもうバラバラしてしまいますよ
バラバラれてしまいます
まあしょうがないんですけどね
だから説法にしたって
そういう 2つの種類があります
で そこで言いたかったのは
修行に入る前に じゃあ修行してみますと決める
そこで修行に入る前にある程度で
この自分の固定概念を破って
価値観を破って 無価値の土台で頑張らなくちゃ
ですから 最初にこのランギというもの
何て言います かんぬきを
もう外さなきゃあかんですね
かんぬき外したんだから
もう無明なくしたんだから
もう終わりということじゃまだない
さらに掘っていかなくちゃいけない
さらに修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
次に見つかるのは何なのかというと
何でしょうか ウッディマーイカ
カエル 掘れない もうバカでかいカエルに出会う
ぶつかっちゃうんです
掘ろうとすると カエルというのはコドゥーバーガッサアディワジャナ
コドゥーっていうのは怒り
ウパーヤーサって何でしたっけ
延々とする もう怒りなんです
え？ 煩悩 梵と煩わして煩悶とする
コドゥーっていうのは一発で出てくる爆発する怒りですね
だから煩悩でいいんですけどね
これでなかなか消えない
もうずっーとなんて言いますかね
どんどんだんだんその嫌な憎しみですね
もう消えないんですね
そうやって続く怒りです
例えば子供と怒る場合は爆発して怒るんだけど
すぐ消える 何もなかったことにすぐなっちゃうんですね
でも他の誰かに怒っちゃうと爆発的に怒りませんだけど
何か言われたんだとかね
侮辱されたんだからといって永久的に覚えておるんですね
ずっとその人に憎しんだり
もういろんなことしたりはすると
その 2番目 そういう怒り
だからコードゥーパヤーサね
種類の怒りあるんですね
だからこちらで言っているのは修行に励みますと
いくらか智慧がないと修行はできません
それで修行を始めますね
始めてやると自分のこの怒りに出会います
自分がかなり怒りに悩んでいるんではない
それからどう頑張っても延々と続く怒りがあるんです
だから まあ嫌だ やめかどうかという怒りもありまして
じゃあまた始まります
でもずっとこの怒りがもうついてくる怒りもあるんですね
どうにもならんと それはこのカエルに例えているんですね
それはすぐに取り除きなさい
で それからさらに掘るですね
それはディダーパトー
そこでこの分かれ道が見つかる
で 分かれ道っていうのはヴィチキッチャー
疑の例えですね 例えばアメリカの砂漠みたいなところで
看板も何もないところで
ずっともう水平線まで道路しか見えない
それで行ったところで綺麗に分かれ道 2つになっちゃうと
看板も何もないとどうしますかね
そこら辺はもう 500KM いっても人はいないとかね
建物もないし 何も目印もないし
ものすごい状態なんです
だって左に曲がっていったら
500KM ぐらい行ったところで何か街に出会うと
あ この街ではなかった
じゃあ戻ろうということになるでしょうに
それで 1000KM になっちゃいますからね
そうすると間に合わないんですよ
そんな感じで まあ今アメリカです
どこでもちゃんと看板がありますけど
もし看板がなくなったらどうなるんですかね
だから分かれ道っていうのはかなりいい例えなんですよ
昔はだいたい看板というのはなかった時代でしょうしね
歩いて歩いて 国から国まで歩いて行ったでしょうね
それで分かれ道に出会った
大変なことなんです だから修行している時でも
まず自分の怒りと戦わなくちゃいけない
それは取り除く で さらに頑張ると
もう疑にやられちゃうんですね
これでいいのか もういくらやっても
なんのただ同じではないか
ワンパターンではないか
本当にもう色々もう悶々と
もう疑ばっかり出てくる
で それを破らなくちゃいけない
破らないでみんなやることは解説して解釈して納得いくんです
そこは一番危険 それは戻ることなんです
今までの妄想概念で あ
こうなったんだから こういう風にテキストにもあったんだから
私は今まで勉強したところでもそういうことあったんだから
なるほどこれだという
解説してああよかったと
それだったらもう終わりなんです
それは戻ったことなんです
解説はしません とにかく先へ
疑を破って先へ行かなくちゃいけないんですね
こういうのは確実に来る問題なんです
研究だから 研究上のことだから
出てこないということはありえないんです
怒り 憎しみに出会う 自分の中にある
次にもう途方に暮れるようなすごい疑にぶつかる
疑を取り除けと 次に出てくるのは
チャンガーラーという入れ物ですね
うんちょっと戻りますけど
注釈書にある説明があります
でも もしかするとご縁縁と長い長い説明ありますけど
なんで怒りはカエルの例えなんですかと
ウッディマーティカっていうのはカエルの種類の種類ですよと
それはほんの小さなカエルですよ
指ぐらいの小さなカエルですよ
どこかに隠れて生活しているんだと
でもちょっといじったらこれぐらい大きくなっちゃう
膨らんじゃうんですね
カエルっていうのはいじめいじちゃう
いじっちゃうと体膨らませちゃうんですね
それはカエルの特色です
それで相手を威嚇するんです
まあ別に誰も怖がらないんですけど
で 本人にとってはこの
大きくなって威嚇したつもりですけどね
この伝統的にカエルは怒りに例えているし
まあまあそれから我々に子供の頃教えた物語ひとつあります
で それは余計に威張るなよという話で
カエルの子供が遊びに出ていくと
お母さんに言ってちょっと遊びに行くぞと言って
遊んでる途中で突然牛がいるのを見るんですね
そしたらすっごいバカでかい牛です
バカでかいじゃなくて
カエルの子供には牛がすごい大きく見えるんです
見たらびっくりして怖くなって
これ怖いと また自分隠れてるところ逃げちゃうんですね
逃げちゃうと子供が怖くて震えて
なんでお前遊ばないで帰ってきたんですか？って言ったら
お母さんすっごい大きいカエルがいたんだ
牛とわからないんだからね
すっごい大きいやつに見つけてやって怖くて逃げたんだ
だからお母さんが子供の怯えを慰めかけなくちゃいけない
まあ大丈夫 私がついてるんだからと
私のほうがもっと大きいでしょうということで
何言うんですか？大きいと言ったってもこれぐらいですかねと言って自分を体膨らませたんだそうですね
いえいえ もっと大きいんですよ
もっと膨らませて じゃあこれぐらいですかねとか
どうったことないやって自分の大きさを見せるんで
子供はもっと大きいんだよと
で もっと膨らませて見せたんですね
子供に自分の自分が大きいと見せたいんですね
子供もっと大きいんだよと
そこであまりも膨らませたところで
カエルがボンと もう爆発して割れてしまっちゃって死んじゃった
だから余計に膨らむなよと
自分の量よりは という教訓のために
小さい時はね まあことわざにして
カエルでも余計に横に膨らんじゃうと爆発しますからねということをよく言われるんです
自分の量を知っておきなさいと
で こちらは怒りに使っていることでも
もしかするとこの例えからどんどん発展していった物語やと思いますけどね
だからこの怒りに例えた怒りっていうのは
どんな膨らむんですね
どんどん膨らんで 自己破壊するまで膨らんでいくんです
[終始背景音楽]だから例えたんだよ
それからウドマータデヴァディッパカーサ
どう出たかというと チャンガラーラに当たってます
それは何かぴったし当てはまる言葉やと思いますけど
このチャンガラーラという言葉の意味はわかってないんですね
こちら入れ物に容器にしているんですけど
それはブッダゴーサ長老の説明見て入れてる言葉なんですね
それはちょっとわかりにくい
その説明は お釈迦様はチャンガラーラっていうのはこの五蓋に例えているんですね
パンチャニーヴァーラナ
チャンガラーラっていうのはパンチャニーヴァーラですよと
五蓋ですよと 五蓋っていうのは欲と怒りと昏沈睡眠と情動と疑ですね
その 5つで心に蓋をかけているんですね
だからいくら瞑想しても第五禅定でも出てこないんですね
この蓋ある場合は 第五禅定ぐらいに進んでいくと
もう昏沈睡眠も情動も全部もう一応消えちゃうんです
膜膜膜もいろいろありますからね
で かなり明るくなりますしね
だからこの瞑想が進めないということは
やっぱりごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ妄想が出ている
それは情動状態ですね
それで睡眠が出てきたりする
睡眠が出ていく中とも
どうも膜が心にかぶっているような感じ
それもあったりするしね
そういうもの あるいはなんか面白くない
なんか早く瞑想終わって何か食べたい
遊びたいといくね もう体のこと可愛くなってしまったりするし
それから怒りが出てきちゃうしね
それ 5つの邪魔があるんですね
それは取り除かないと第五禅定にでも進めないんですね
ですから それが入れ物
器 容器  その容器っていうのを直訳するとするとどうなる？ それわからないんです
ブッダゴーサ長老に わかるんだったら私もわかってますけどね
だからどうなのかなと思って
英語でもわかってないと思います
これは研究してみないと
もっともっと学問学術的な辞書を引いてみて
これのサンスクリットの語鑑を調べて
いくか あるいはパーリ語でいくかとかね
これはおそらくインドで使っている言葉だったら
サンスクリット語でも見つからないんです
パーリクリットの辞書を何か引いてみないと
パーリクリットだったら
おそらくチャンガラーラなんとか似ている言葉が出ている可能性がありますね
だからこれ日常性 もうそこら辺あったものなんですよ
当時の社会で 使われてたものを
だからすぐわかる喩えでなきゃ意味がないんだから
とにかくこれがあると邪魔
これは取り除かないと進めないという
前回古い言葉好きっておっしゃってたけど
そういう疑いもありますけどね
蓋がついてればいいじゃない
蓋がついてるもんな  まあまあ一応持っていくと
何かいろいろ蓋ついてるもの
蓋つきの入れ物を見つかるんですね
で これがまた進めなくなっちゃうんですね
だから蓋つきの入れ物っていうのは五蓋であって
ニーヴァーラナ だから五蓋は別に勉強してみてください
カーマ チャンダラ パーサ
ウッダッチ クッチイト
ニヴィラナ 打ち切っちゃっていいものなんですね
その 5つを取り除かないと心は成長しない
それ取り除きなさいと
そこで進んだらどうなるんでしょうか
ここには観です  一応経典の中でもこの五蓋の説明はあります
カーマッチャンダ・ニーヴァラナン
カーマッチャンダっていうのは
見たい 聞きたい 食べたいという体に対する欲
体がかわいくてほとんど瞑想が進めないでしょうに
やっぱり寝なくちゃあかんだとかね
ちゃんと食べなくちゃいけないんだとか
長い間座れないとかね
もうとにかく体のこと
何かちょっと風邪気味ですよとかね
自分がちょっと腰が痛いんだからね
ちょっといろんなことばっかり言うんですね
もう嫌になっちゃう 私はあんまりもうそれでも頑張れとは言わないんです
で 卒中だからね 一日で帰るんです
なんで？ちょっと風邪気味で
それぐらい腰抜けですかね
人間っていうのは で かなりね
頭の悪い人だと結構それは途中でも帰ると
もう帰るときは原因聞いたら本当にもうこれで人間かと聞きたいんですけど
やっぱり強引に言ってはいけないんだからね
まあ帰ったけど まあ若い人にとっては一応一言葉言います
でも私にしてみれば あなたはまあそれぐらいのことは気にしないで行った方がいいと思いますけど
まあどうしてもそれは強引には言いませんと
まあ年取ってると一言葉言わない
あ そうですか あれが通りそうなっても腰抜けは
だったらもうもう当然無理でしょうしね
何のこともないのは ちょっとなんかちょっともうくしゃみが出たぐらいとかね
ちょっとお腹がちょっと痛くなったとかね
頭がちょっと痛くなったとか
それぐらいでも あー大変だ
これだったら死ぬんだぞとかね
だからそれは一番目の害ですね
カーマッチャンダ 体のことかわいくて修行はできなくなる
進めなくなる カーマッチャンダ・ニーヴァラナ
二番目はジャーパッダ・ニーヴァラナ
怒りのことですね そんな気に入らない
あの人はうるさいとかね
隣に座ってる人うるさくて瞑想できないとか
時計の音はうるさくて瞑想できないとかね
で いろいろことを言うという場合
もうできない それだったら
なんか暑くてジメジメして
なんかもう嫌ですよ 気持ち悪いんですよ
なんだったらできないってことになっちゃいますね
三番目はティーナ・ミッダ
昏眠ですね 眠たくて眠たくてね
してることで ウッダッチェ・クッチャっていうのは
まあ情動と疑いですね
もう疑問ばっかりで 頭の中でいろいろいろいろ疑問ばっかり
それで進めなくなります
ウッダッチェ・クッチャっていうのは混乱状態
落ち着きのない状態 それからヴィチキッチャ
五番目は疑い 次にクンモ
クンモっていうのは亀
で 亀を取り除けと エータン・ウパーダーナ・クンダナン・アディワチャナン
セイヤ・ティーダン・ルーパ・ウパーダーナ・クンダッサ・ヴェーダナー・サンニャー・サンカーラ・ヴィンニョー
五取蘊のこと 五蘊のこと
いわゆる体のことなんです
色受想行識に体五つに分けてるんです
だから修行する人がこの五蓋とんだところでものすごい頭がものすごく冴えてきて
ものすごくひとかけらも眠気がないし
修行する自信もあるし
何の疑いもないし 妄想ごちゃごちゃ来ることもないし
綺麗に瞑想できるようになってくる
それで色受想行 それでなってから色受想行識と五つに分けて見るんです
体を それは亀に例えているんです
いわゆる煩悩はどこにあるかと
まず物体に対して煩悩がありますね
それから感覚ですね 感覚に対して煩悩が生まれるわけですね
次にサンニャ サンニャっていうのはいっぱい色々概念持ってるでしょうね
それに対してすごい執着
私のものっていうあるでしょうしね
で サンカーラっていうのはもういつでも湧いてくる
何かやりたい 何かやりたいというエネルギーでしょ
瞬間でもじっとしていられないんですね
何か何か次から次へとずっと人間やりっぱなしで
そのエネルギー それが自分やと思って
そこで煩悩が生まれる
それから五番目は心なんですね
認識する機能 これ単なる物体といったっても認識機能入ってるんだからね
認識機能にヴィンヤーナと言うんです
すごい明確です それは明確に分かれるのは本当に頭が五蓋から飛んじゃったら
あ これが五蘊やと見えてくるんです
盛に五蘊の瞑想したってもね
意味はないんですけど
やっぱり自然に進んで研究だからね
かっこつけて私に五蘊の観察の教えてくださいとかね
言われる時もありますけどね
まあダメだなと この人は
いて私はもう希望なしというバツ印を入れてから
自分も各人にプログラム持ってますからね
この人はここまでや この人はここまでやと
そうすると明確に説明してあげるわけです
説法 で 頑張る分はね 来世に徳にもなりますからね
でも研究の方を間違ったらいい結果出るっていうことは絶対ありえないしね
やっぱり自然に次の課題
次の課題 次の課題にぶつかるんです
そこで私が言ったことは同じことを返してくれると
もうすぐわかるんです
私があなた説明したんだからと言って
じゃあ修行してみるんだよと言って
私にまた同じ言葉返してくると
もう 同じ言葉返ってこないんです
自分で研究してるんだから
だから騙せません 騙そうとは思ってますけどね
指導者をね 難しいんです
すごいズルいんです 説明はしますよ
ちゃんと仏教用語に則って
実際に修行したところで本人がレポートするんです
レポートは本物かないかっていうことはすぐわかるんです
うん それでこの五蘊じゃなくて五蓋なくなったところで五蘊の観察に行くんですね
パジャハ パンチョ ウパーダナッカンテ
五蘊に対する執着を捨てなさいと
さらに掘りなさい それでアシスーナ
何か刃物見つかるんですね
刃物といってもあのなんだっけ？肉を切る
砕く え？ それコショウですか？アシスーナっていうのは
まあ肉を切る刃物 刃物と肉を切るために使う台ですね
それ見つかるということで
それはパンチャンナン カーマグナーナン アディワチャナ
あの五欲のことやと 五欲っていうのは眼耳鼻舌身という五つありますね
それに外の世界から色声香味触でしたっけ
五つぶつかるんですね
目には形がぶつかる 耳に音をぶつかる
鼻に香りがぶつかっちゃう
それで舌に味がぶつかる
体にいろいろ感触ぶつかっちゃうんですね
そこで欲が生まれる それを五欲と言うんですね
だからアシスーナなんですね
ぶつかってボンと欲が出てくる刀があって台があって
そこ上で肉を切っちゃいますからね
だから耳があって音が触れると
どんどんあぁ綺麗な音ではないか
なんて美しい声ですかとかね
もっともっと聞きたいとか
どんどん欲が漏れちゃうんですね
湧き出すんですね それで舌にいろんなものを触れると
なんて美味しいですかとか
そこからまた煩悩が湧き出しちゃうんですね
だから欲がその 5つの場所で湧き出す
体に何か触れると またなんと気持ちいいんですかとかね
また湧き出すちゃう だからこの 5つの場所で欲が湧いてくるんですね
それはカーマグナ カーマグナっていうのは本当はこの外のものなんです
体に触れるものにカーマグナというんです
それがあの浅草なですね
あのまな板と 刀ですね
次にこれも捨てなさい
取り除けと さらに掘りなさいと
そこで肉の塊というか
肉塊 肉片が見つかるんですね
肉片はナンディラーガ
ナンディラーガの日本訳は
肉片とは非道の動機  非道の動機
これはあの卒中出てくる用語じゃないんです
ナンディラーガっていうのは
あのー だいたい五欲に対して使っていて
たまたま使ってる言葉で
この仏教でこの規制的な道義語としては使わないものなんですけど
古い古い経典などではやっぱり使っている言葉なんです
ナンディラーガ 例えば一番古い経典の中では
このアルボラマンが欲は世の中のものは欲ですよと
世の中は美しいものがいっぱいあるんだ
それが欲ですよ と言ったらお釈迦様違いますよと
美しいものはただの美しいもので
それについてる人間の気鈍
人間の気鈍が欲ですよ
例えば花が咲いている
別にどういったことはないんだけど
それ見て なんと なんて綺麗やと思ったところが欲ですよと
花が咲いてそれだけ そこら辺の綺麗な音があるんだったら
まあ音が綺麗な音があるんですよと
音ですよと言えば もうただの対象ですね
認識の なんて綺麗な音ですかと言うと
惹かれる場合はそれが欲というんですね
ですから この肉を切る台があって
刀が その刀で肉を切ってるんですね
だから肉破片はこのナンディラーガ
心に生まれる欲なんですね
それも取り除きなさいと
そのナンディラーガも取り除いちゃうと
ナンディラーガっていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身に情報が触れても
煩悩が生まれないようにする
だからもう目にはいろんな形が触れる
触れる 触れる 見えるんですけど
煩悩の湧き出しことはなし
耳に音が触れるんだけど
何の音かと知ってるし
理解もできるし でも煩悩があの汚染が湧き出してはこない
ご飯も食べたりするんだけど
何で美味しいかとかね
という風に煩悩だけは出てこない
ただ食べてるだけ 聞いてるだけ
だから昨日質問したあの若者にしても
やっぱりあの一生懸命瞑想一人で頑張って頑張って
もうかなりまあかなり進んでますけどね
煩悩が湧き出さなくなっちゃって
ハメになっちゃって だからえらい心配しているところなんですね
だからみんなと一緒にいても
別になんとか何も面白くなんともないんだと
だから これはみんなの前であの子は喋っちゃってね
本当に申し訳ないんですけど
まあ喋ってはいけないとその本人は知ってはいたんですけどね
私がまずかったんですね
まあいいよと言ったんだから
だからこの 阿羅漢になったっていうことは
このどうしても何が体に触れても
目に何が触れても 貪瞋痴の煩悩は目のところで湧いてこない
耳のところで湧いてこない
アホになったわけじゃない
見えるものは見える それもちゃんと判断できる
それは煩悩はなしっていう
ですから そのマンスペーシ肉片を捨てちゃう
それで最終解決なんですね
次に見つかるのはナーガ
龍というか蛇ですね この場合
龍でいいと思いますけどね
ナーガっていうのは蛇っていうことで
だいたい龍神というかね
蛇神様で思ってますからね
それはキーナーサヴァッサディヴァチャナ
悟った人に使う言葉ですよと
それで修行は終了するんです
だからティッッタトゥナーガ
まあそれで終わりと 放っておきなさい
それ以上掘るなよ 偉大なる龍に出会ったんだからね
だから掘ったのはこの龍に出会うためなんです
アリ塚っていうのは だいたい蛇の住処なんです
決まってるんです それ
掘って掘って蛇が見つかったら
それさらに掘る必要はなくなるんです
そこでマーナーガンガッテーシ
ナーガとはもうぶつからない方がいいと
それで礼をしなさいと
そこで修行は終了するということで
はっきりとした修行の終了なんですね
それでなぞなぞの説明なんですね
いわゆるこの修行の過程をちょっとしたカラクリを使って説明しているんです
で 同じくこの 10種類の中で
またまた同じ修行の過程を語っているんです
それからも出会うと思います
修行すると真面目に修行する人々はね
そういう過程で進んではいくんです
それは逆になるとかありえないし
私は立派だから 昔から私にはないぞとか
それはありえないんです
で 基本的な法則ですからね
その法則で進んでいくんです
私は特別に今日は時間をかけて説明したのは
別に私の勉強のためなんですけど
なぜかというと あの ある
あの どこでしたっけ？愛知学園の教授からね
手紙があったんですね
なんかあの 私は仏教はすごい論理的で科学的だと話して
それを聞いてすごい感銘しましたと
自分の研究分野は書いてなかったんだけど
それで自分がまた同じ大学の大学院にまた入って
仏教学に入って パーリ語やらいろいろ今勉強しているんだよと
でも全然科学的な話とか全然見つかりませんと
こんなものはどこにあるんですか？という質問があったんです
だから この経典 この経典だと私は書いてあげなくちゃいけないんだけど
そんな単純なことじゃないんです
いくら大学で研究したっても
ただそのままずっと読んでそれで終わるだけで
何が科学的かと 私に言えば
一言葉一言葉 全部厳密で論理的で合理的で言っていることなんです
例えば出世間敵やということ自体もすごい科学的でしょうに
でも大学では出世間それで終わっちゃうんですね
色世間 何が科学や 色世間で何なのかって見てほしいんですね
出世間で何なのかと見て
そうすると 超越した神秘的な世界ではなくて
すごい合理的なことをお釈迦様は出世間やと言っているんではないかと
だからチャレンジする精神は立派で
もう大変な立派な人やと思いますけど
でも だからといって仏教学の教授たちが一欠片も見つからないと思いますね
科学性というのは だから一貫して科学的なんです
一言葉一言葉 すべて合理的
論理的なんです たまたま入ってる物語とかね
神のエピソードとかはもうエピソードだから
そのまま取り除くことできますからね
ある日は神が来てこう言ったと
それはなくても言ったことがあるでしょうにね
だから神が来ても 大蛇仙が来て
悪魔が来て質問して お釈迦様は悪魔にそう答えたらっても
その説法が悪魔でなくても成り立つんですよ
だから一貫して科学的
論理的なんです だから
なんで悪魔が入ったり神が入ったりするか
それはちょっとした文化背景であって
まあそれは別に必要ない
だから彼にどう答えるべきかっていうことは
私はもう結構研究しなくちゃいけないっていうことになって
だから私の解釈方法っていうのは
習うためにはかなり時間かかるんですよ
学者として習うためには
並の知識ではなくて かなり研究して
仏教だけではなくて いろんな思想
方法とかね 全く未だかつてない学問の世界を作らないと
それも厳密に科学的に作らないと成り立たないもので
世界ではないんですよ
このブッダは科学的に語ったという風に
ブッダの教えを解釈する
そういう方法っていうのはね
だから これは一人の人間が一人で踏ん張ってもね
まあ認めてくれないということで
で もうもうやめてしまったんですけど
私にしてみれば一貫してもう科学的なんです
どんな経典ですかと聞いたっても
この経典は科学的ですよと
そんな言えるものじゃないんです
どっちでも同じです ただ
例えばパンニャーというアリエパンニャーと書いているんだから
はっきりしてアリエパンニャーっていうのは
空住滅道による智慧であって
空住滅道が世の中で実際にあるものに空と空の現れっていう
それにアリエパンニャーと呼んであって
非科学的に神秘的な形而上学的な知恵に
スリランカ人が 悟ったら消えちゃうとかね
空で空を飛べるとか そんな風なパンニャーではないんです
はっきりした合理的な智慧なんです
だからそこら辺ちょっと頭を整理したかったんです
そこ経典を見ながら では
そこで話を終了いたします
亀とか五蘊の説明はまだない
じゃあ説明しましたよ
なんで寝ていたんですか
なんで亀？ 蛇だったらダメでしょう
例えば青大将と言ったっても1本だから
亀だったら首と足4本あるでしょうに
という風に注釈書にあるんだけど
なんで亀ですかね  分かれ道の儀が説明されているけど
五蘊の中 五蓋の中にある儀はどのような儀ですか
ああああ  分かれ道にある儀が
はいはい おそらくこのどちらも経典ではいちいちチャーニはしていますね
ですから とりあえず危険を防ぐために普通の道でした方がいいと思いますが
それからもう一つ 経典は先待ってます
そちらではマッガーマッガナーダスタナというドーヒードー
道と非道を分離する知恵というステージがあるんです
それとのしかすると絡み合っていると思います
でも 私にはそれほどそれはそれだというぐらいの情報がないんです
3冊の経の中で調べてないんだけど
頭の中では入ってるんだから
ちょっと頭の中で調べてみると
出せる証拠はないんです
だからおそらくこれ修行には一応半信半疑でチャレンジするんですよ
本当かなというね 半信半疑でチャレンジして
それで怒りとか何とかとかね
乗り越えていったところで
やっぱりこれが道やと
というところで この半信半疑は消えちゃうんですね
それでずっといくんですね
この半信半疑消えるところだと思います
最初の分かれ道は 儀は
で 半信半疑消えても儀が消えたわけじゃないんです
真理わかったわけじゃないんですね
それで本物の儀に後でぶつかるんですね
本物の儀が取り除いたら
もう預流果に悟ってるんだからね
ブッダはその儀はもう最初から順番で言ってないんです
もう五蓋は取り除けと言えば
もう預流果 一来果の方であって
それでこのナンディラーガというもの
それ取りのそれは阿羅漢のレベルで説明しているんですね
専門的にするとかなりかなりややこしくというかね
かなりまだ時間かかります
とにかく阿羅漢ということ
悟りということを説明解説するとき
定義するときはナンディラーガないこと
ナンディっていうのは喜ぶことで
ラーガっていうのは欲なんですね
ただ 物事について喜んでいること
生まれることについて
生まれて生きていることについては
我々はどこかで喜んでいるんですね
それがナンディラーガなんです
だからドゥッカわかると喜びが飛んじゃうんですよ
やっぱりドゥッカだよと
で もう二度と戻らないようにナンディラーガが飛んでいっちゃうんですね
そうするともう悟りということになっちゃうんですね
だから他の場所で悟りって何のことかというと
苦渋を知ってわかることやと言っちゃうんですね
だから言葉変えるってことで変えるだけで
こちらはもっと具体的でわかりやすく
この生に喜んじゃうんですね
やっぱり 今苦しいんだけど
先に楽しみがあるんだぞというふうな感じで
でも今食べるご飯はまずいんだけど
明日美味しいご飯食べますよと
ということで 明日にするんですよ
喜びは そうやって人間というのは喜びを喜んでいるんです
喜びを貪っている  喜びを貪っているんですね
それはナンディラーガというんですね
何か見たらいいなと思っちゃうし
いい いい そうじゃないと思っても
他のところでいいものがあるでしょうと思っちゃうんですね
別なものを見ようと 本を読んで
あ これちょっと面白い
じゃあ別な本読もうと
ということがナンディラーガなんです
みんなで みんなで音楽を聴きましょうと
やっぱりこの曲はちょっと気に入る
じゃあ次の曲に行きましょう
ナンディラーガでいっちゃうんですね
やっぱり確かにこの曲は良くないと
音はうるさいとかね で
そういう風にこれを客観的に見ようとしないんです
じゃあ次に飛ばしましょうと
これは普通の人間の生き方なんです
ナンディラーガの生き方なんです
ナンディラーガ取り除くことは完全悟りの世界
だからこのいくらか欲が薄くなって
でもナンディラーガがあると
かなりショック状態で生活しなくちゃいけないんです
では  [笑い]